the uk is basking in a long overdue heat
wave
daring people to believe the pandemic's
nearly over
on june the 21st the government plans to
scrap all coveted restrictions in
england ready for a summer to remember
with the
restrictions going down in quite soon
i think it should be normality coming
quite quite quickly
definitely that mood has changed in the
last few weeks
and i think everybody is desperate for a
bit of a break
but scientists are increasingly nervous
according to the latest data
the country's in the early stages of a
third wave of infections
with the rate growing fastest amongst 10
to 14 year olds
it's very clear that we're in a public
health crisis now and right now cases
and hospitalizations are increasing
we're seeing rapid spread with the more
transmissible variant
um while only about 38 percent of our
population is fully vaccinated and we
need to really curb that early on
so that we don't end up in the same
situation we were uh
several times so far we've acted late
which has led to
sort of lockdowns that have been very
prolonged on sunday the uk recorded
3 000 new coronavirus cases for the
fifth day in a row that's the highest
figure
since the start of april the so-called
indian variant thought to be much more
virulent
than other variants is now dominant in
several parts of the country
if the last 12 months have taught us
anything it's that waves can start small
and quickly grow even with the country's
successful vaccination program
cases are doubling every week providing
opportunities for even more potentially
harmful mutations
the government's now racing to get as
many people as possible
vaccinated with 15 000 jabs administered
at this
rugby stadium on monday alone
the government says there can be no room
for complacency
but as yet there are no plans to delay
next month's unlocking
heat wave or third wave a return to
normality feels
tantalizingly close too close for any
last
minute mistakes neve barker al jazeera
london